so I told you earlier this week they
will not stop until the whistleblower
ends up dead or hurt and Donald Trump
jr. has now started tweeting the alleged
whistleblowers name so I'll tell you now
I'm not going to say the whistleblowers
alleged name for the time being you know
eventually if it becomes public
knowledge if it's confirmed if the
person goes public okay I understand by
the way that me saying it is not going
to be what gets the whistleblower killed
but I'm not gonna make myself a part of
the problem this is not a name that's
been confirmed at this point by the
whistleblowers attorney so I'm not going
to say it but I am going to talk about
what Donald Trump jr. is doing and what
they're all trying to do but I do want
to remind you upfront about what I've
been saying for a few days now which is
that the particulars of this
whistleblower are no longer important
because there are so many other people
that have corroborated the Ukraine
Fiasco and the quid pro quo but we're
going to get back to that so over the
weekend Republican Senator Rand Paul
went to a Trump rally in Lexington
Kentucky and he called for the media to
print the whistleblowers name there's a
name that's been floated around now for
a couple of weeks privacy advocate Rand
Paul asking the media to violate the
protections afforded to whistleblowers
by our system of law doesn't make sense
but it does when you understand that
Rand Paul is a total tool of whoever he
believes can put him into a position of
higher power and privilege Donald Trump
has been referencing the whistleblower
as a spy as a traitor and now in comes
Donald Trump jr. tweeting the name of
the alleged whistleblower and so is
Breitbart by the way Don Jr actually
tweeting the Breitbart article in which
the whistleblowers alleged name is
publicized so as far as the legal case
against Trump I believe it's abundantly
clear that now that they are publishing
the whistleblowers alleged name this is
the beginning of the obstruction of
justice this is the beginning of the
witness tampering on this particular
scandal on the Ukraine scandal now as
far as the moral case against what
they're doing there's a reason the
whistleblower was being protected the
anonymity of the whistleblower was being
protected because their life and
life of family members are instantly at
risk if their identity is known the
Trump's don't care about that people
dying from California wildfires who
cares no more aid to California says
Donald Trump the whistleblower and their
family could be at risk of being outed
could be at risk from being outed rather
who cares we're gonna out them anyway
Don Jr doesn't fall far from the tree
as far as this is concerned he has
Trump's fatality retaliatory instincts
his violent tendencies his disregard for
the well-being of others particularly
when there's some personal benefit to be
gained at the expense of the well-being
of others complete disregard for the law
and as far as the law is concerned there
are legal experts who are saying if this
were anyone other than the family of the
President of the United States they
would have been arrested for doing what
Donald Trump did and what Breitbart did
with Donald Trump jr. did and what
Breitbart did now let's get back to the
key thing the trumpets and the
Republicans have lost the argument on
substance on the Ukraine Fiasco right
there is no more way to argue that there
was not a quid pro quo because it's been
corroborated there is no way to argue
that Donald Trump wasn't personally
involved both in the quid pro quo but
also in the trying to cover-up the quid
pro quo with a truncated transcript and
asking William bard to go out as I told
you earlier in the program and announce
that Trump broke no laws there's no way
to defend the substance anymore so what
they're doing is they're focusing on the
whistleblower they're doing character
assassination they're impugning the
motives of the alleged whistleblower all
of the things that they are known for
because remember ambassador to the EU
Gordon sunland's now says there was a
quid pro quo Ukraine expert Lieutenant
Colonel Alexander VIN Minh exposed the
same and that they were deliberately
removing references to Joe Biden from
the truncated transcript of the July 25
phone call between Trump and Ukrainian
president Solinsky so what we need to
continue focusing on no matter what the
original alleged whistleblowers
or their motivations or anything about
it is that the story has been widely
corroborated period and this is what is
being distorted or covered up or ignored
by what has been taking place here now
there's another element to this which is
sort of an ugly reality which is that we
increasingly have there's this
incestuous nature even though we're
supposed to have separation of powers
that's what it's literally called
separation of powers and we have no
separation we increasingly have our
systems of checks and balances either
controlled by or subjugated by that
which they are supposed to be keeping
accountable in this case the President
of the United States I mean just look
across at all I was forgetting the
number but there's some rapidly growing
number of hi judges
important appellate judges and federal
judges that have been selected by Donald
Trump now if you believe that judges are
simply applying the law to the facts and
making impartial decisions then you
wouldn't worry about this we know that's
not the case though we have a Supreme
Court increasingly controlled by Donald
Trump and we have lower judges lower
than the Supreme Court still federal and
appellate courts controlled by people
selected by Donald Trump we have a
Republican Party that even if deep down
they know that what we have in the White
House is an atrocity and an abomination
they put their finger to the wind and
they do what's politically expedient and
they want power and they want to be in
the good graces of the President of the
United States it's appealing it's
attractive it's exciting so they are
certainly not going to hold Donald Trump
accountable unless the public turns on
Trump but as we learned yesterday nearly
two-thirds of Trumpets say there is
nothing Trump could do that would get
them to no longer support from so the
Republican Party that ship has sailed
we have the Attorney General of the
United States who is potentially
implicated in the Ukraine fiasco as we
discussed earlier today selected by
Donald Trump and functioning as a
henchmen propagandist for Donald Trump
in almost all of the ways Donald Trump
wants
- other than refusing to go out and say
Trump broke no laws so we have the
number one stick to the facts which are
as far as the whistle blower is
concerned that initial whistle blower we
want to protect them of course but
they're increasingly irrelevant to
knowing what happened because we have
corroboration from multiple other
sources including VIN VIN and Sandman
okay and then number two that there is
going to need to be some accounting here
there's going to need to be some kind of
reckoning with the reality that up until
now executive power has sort of worked
okay because we didn't have a president
as audacious as Donald Trump and as
brazen as Donald Trump in ignoring or
superseding the checks and balances that
were at least ostensibly set up to
control or to check the president's
power so maybe the system we have of
checks and balances and separation of
powers is actually inadequate to deal
with the president that is this brazen
and audacious that's the big picture
that at some point there will have to be
an accounting of I say we remove Trump
first if I voting him out in November of
2020 and then deal with that